well a dancers life is most definitely
demanding and challenging I mean you
give up a lot of your of what would be
considered as a sort of normal life in
order to achieve the kind of physical
perfection it's pretty tough on you
mentally it's a very competitive art
form there are a lot of wonderful
dancers out there not so many jobs in
the in the in the big gray companies you
begin usually dancers sort of begin
around I guess seven eight years old
sometimes a lot younger sometimes the
ballerinas start you know three or four
their mothers enlist them in in Valley
Schools and you go through I guess your
formative years you're going through a
period when you're constantly being
scrutinized by other people you learn to
be very self scrutinizing really early
on about the about you know the way that
you move the way that you look so it can
be pretty challenging as an
eleven-year-old I mean I went to a
pretty strict school I went to the Royal
Ballet School in London and things have
changed i think now but in those days
you know we were told okay your your
legs are getting fat you can't eat
potatoes don't don't give that kid
potatoes you know things like that crazy
things that when you're when you're
little you it's that's a lot to deal
with I don't think it's like that
anymore I think time times have changed
and and the more informed and the
smarter young people young dancers are
the the more this the more the life the
more the environment around the training
of a dancer has to has to kind of give
and give or take a little bit
every every dancer takes a class every
day a morning class it's it's based on a
technique that's been around for
hundreds of years it's a series of
exercises that begin at the bar everyone
you know even non-dancers have heard of
you know dances being at the bar that
doesn't mean that they're ordering a
vodka tonic although that usually
happens to be a bit heavy but so you
start at the bar you do a series of
exercises and then you step away from
the bar and the bar work is is there to
kind of stabilize the body so you you
then move into the center of the room
and you do similar exercises but without
the support of the bar in order to kind
of gain your strength and you know the
class builds in intensity and you end up
with a lot of pirouettes a lot of turns
a lot of jumps to really get the body
moving and that usually happens right at
the end of the day and then a
professional dancer will go with a
15-minute break will move into usually
what adds up to about a 6 5 or 6 hour
rehearsal day where they'll rehearse
intensely with with the choreographer or
a ballet master either creating new work
on their bodies or learning existing
work that's just being taught for you
know an upcoming performance and then
around six o'clock you'll have a little
break you'll grab some food quickly then
you'll start to put your makeup on put
your costume on and you know seven
thirty eight o'clock its curtain up and
you're out onstage until ten-thirty
eleven o'clock curtain comes down you're
completely knackered everything hurts
your joints are you know screwed up
you've pulled the muscle usually you go
home take a hot bath go to sleep and get
up the next day and do it all over again
so your life kind of is put on hold for
you know for those periods of time when
you're in when you're in performance
rehearsal and performance
you